retour à présent sur le décès à d'abdel
malacca droukdal le chef d'al qaïda au
maghreb islamique a été tué mercredi
lors d'une opération française dans le
nord du mali
on l'a appris ce week-end pour autant la
situation sécuritaire du sel est
toujours aussi instable le point tout de
suite avec elle à medjahed abdelmalek
droukdal était loin d'être le seul
leader islamiste au sahel et après la
disparition du chef d'aqmi
trois grandes figures du terrorisme
domine plus que jamais la zone dite des
'trois frontière entre le niger le
burkina faso et le mali depuis plus de
huit ans la région est endeuillé par des
violences qui ne cesse de s'aggraver
après la crise malienne de 2012 la
nébuleuse djihadiste plus ou moins unis
dans les années 2000 s'est fissuré en
deux groupes l'un est affiliée à
al-qaïda l'autre adech et tous deux sont
engagés dans une lutte d'influencé
sociale la disparition de doodle
pourrait avoir un effet cela a mis
aujourd'hui et peut-être renforcer
relativement à l'état islamique qui
pourrait gagner en influence dans le
cadre de cette lutte de rivalité qui
l'oppose à aqmi dans la région des trois
frontières
la mort d'abdel malek droukdel est un
coût symbolique fort porté par la france
en guerre dans la région des trois
frontières une zone d'opération de
plusieurs factions terroristes
il ya d'abord le groupe de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans liés à al qaïda
dont fait partie aqmi l'alliance formée
en 2017 réunit également d'autres
mouvements les principaux restent en
deçà hardin dirigé par le touareg iyad
agali dans nord du mali et la katiba
massina fondé cette fois ci dans le
centre du mali par le prédicateur poehl
amadou coup fois depuis sa création le
gsm a revendiqué les principaux
attentats dans le sahel
un autre groupe est très présent sur
l'échiquier sahélien dèche ce mouvement
dans le triangle frontalier nigéro
malienne burkinabé dirigé par adnane
abou walid sahraouis désigné ennemi
prioritaire de la france dans la région
dans le vaste territoire désertique
sahélien l'insécurité fragilise toujours
un peu plus les états pourtant les
mission internationale de lutte contre
le terrorisme se sont multipliés ces
dernières années dans la zone aux
commandes les forces de l'opération
française barkan celle de la mission des
nations unies pour la stabilisation au
mali ou encore les troupes américaines
de l'africom dans l'ouest du niger
principalement puis depuis plusieurs
mois des opérations sont menées par la
force conjointe des pays du g5 celle
composée de quelques 5000 soldats
enfin la coalition européenne takouba
avec une centaine de militaires au
départ devrait être lancé dans la région
d'ici à la fin de l'été